皆さん最近のニュース見ましたでしょうかツイッターとかでもニュースになってたと
思うんですけど特価月5と
候補で静岡って出てきます凄い産経ニュースとかヤフーニュースにもなっている
ニーズです静岡市葵区瀬名川の重篤化に大きな
静岡市の品がって場所を中心に8体長1メートルのトカゲが逃げ出しているみたいで
ございます
が警察訓が捕まえようとして逃げ出しちゃったらしいので俺が捕まえるしかないやろう
と俺たちが俺たちが静岡市の平和を守るしかないやろうということでへ通報する方短所
商品とかでもいいなぁやっぱ近所のペットが逃げたものらしい
ねだからもう嫌じゃん立って歩いててさ
boss 1メートルの影が飛び出してきたら嫌でしょとりあえず今我々の地域にその
ようなに怪獣が出ているということは我々が何とかするしかないということでなんとか
してエナガは中心に峠を探して捕まえて静岡の平和を守ろうと思います
では行こう
ジャンキージョンボイェ a 国交が千浜の田んぼランスよ国家
プレイ月込みとかしますか人がいたらキーという歩いてる人いたら聞いてみよ
せません
たのー
この辺で何たザバハゲ
いい見てないですからどこら辺で見たかってわかりますか
ございますありがとうあっったんですかあれございます
実行高の先輩子なんですよねっ知って心読み取ってなーいでナンパ傷つかの
まあいるかいないかで言うといないねぇあっえっ
夏ってざーすっですみません
なんかここら辺でトカゲが出たって話を聞いんけどもうああっ
どこら辺で計ありますかねこれドロー姫
もう一個のに描いておりだろうとにあるでしょちゃんみたい
by 火星の声そう張らず後ろ謎うーんもうちょっと頑張って見つけます
ライブ僕の予想といい場所が違ったもの場所を確定したねまっつかー
も強くん
ブーバーこんちゃーっ
ちょっとだけですかァーーットカゲですかァーーッ
あ渡すと影ですかかけて見つかったんですかまだ今井見つかってないよ
なるんさざまぁ何の延長さんだよこの前撮影でお世話になった
あっああんだめなんか静岡の動物園の園長さんも来てました
egoist 第二凄いねこれみんなトカゲとだけ三の影勢7これめっちゃ人いますよ
オート影がいい
10区域内に入っておりますまるリバー言い方いう
ああああああ
雑貨久しぶりですね
ちょっと動画って言っても大丈夫よ当然脳深部店
分かっている静岡の悲痛の念ちょー緊張ですよろしくお願いします
以前撮影同社になったんですけどもその動画の url 明日に寄せておけるピン
チェックしてください
何にいいますか水辺にも現れる可能性がある
こう喉が渇くからけどこういうなんか乾燥してるところでいないですよね
ikea だけどね今はこう日光浴をするために来てそこで体温を上げる可能性がある
のでああなる前に g くらいでしょ
ちょうど今ベストの超わー
つけたら警察に負けずので風にウッドバランス集まる
よろしくまた遊びにください音ゲーって名前とかあったんですか私からあ
なかったりないけどこれで見えたよいいです
ええええええ
エンツォさんの話による頭がこの日中に時ぐらいが丁度日向ぼっこをしにくるやすいの
でこういうアスファルトのとこだけでも結構出てくるかもしれないということです
あと逃げ出した家の娘
僕のドロミテいますチャンスなんとので時間的に本体代ジャンス
なるべくちょっと動いて探してみましょう
[音楽]
ブーバーし
つかれちゃうっ
もしれないがいい
たーーーーねー冷たいのが吹っ飛んだとに引っ張ってまで眠い are you do
あっ幌凄いと思えるスイミースイミーねー
全然系でもないんだけどここにこの宛てに入ること間違いないとっ
好きないなぁ
見ないなぁん
ええええええ
teame
アーヘンにゃうううっうぅうううーん
ここが第一目撃情報でした高目撃情報があった場所らしいです
で向こうの方に歩いていっ
いないすねほんとん
[音楽]
me
ame
持ってい
ん
[音楽]
ni
んんん
ana
ana 機 ni
ん
持った
ん tan
me
分
yeah
[音楽]
kimi ni
b 4 le
[音楽]
aname
i am
me
君の ni
ni
n ame
aname
1尾使わなかったんで
どこがて寝てるのかな
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ